[Music]
Anaheim California the most populated
city in Southern California's famed
Orange County
and home to a family-run restaurant
named Luigi's the Italia
it was opened in 1981 by a promising
young chef with a dream Luigi had his
own my dream was to always own a
restaurant
and my dream did come true when my
father took a loan on his house and we
opened a small restaurant and with the
aid of his father Dominic Luigi was able
to make the restaurant successful for
many years
Luigi's is definitely an Anaheim staple
who is our favorite place to go whenever
I used to come here as a kid it was just
a really really great atmosphere
in 1999 Dominic retired to Italy and
brought in his other son Tony to help
Luigi Run the restaurant
Tony and Luigi have totally different
ways of running the restaurant there's
like two different sets of standards
we've been lazy taking shortcuts
whenever Luigi's here Luigi wants to be
more Hands-On there's more yelling and
screaming they're interfere with Mike
looking get the [__] out of here I don't
agree with the way he runs it and the
way he does it we start pointing fingers
at each other and we fight there's
there's rational you can't lose it like
that
[__] I gotta pissed off a lot of times
because Tony's got to take a more
serious of the job
and say you know what it's not fair
I think I'm being pushed to the Limit
Luigi's yelling Grace is yelling I'm
trying to keep my sanity here it's too
much
I got a headache
there is a lot of drama that goes on
here that's a bottle of [__]
when I'm gone everything no good the
arguments and the stress of the
restaurant it does spill over to the
dining room a lot
miners don't want to go to to this
restaurant or any restaurant to get
yelled at
him
well you come in report complain or what
Luigi Tony Grace they just can't seem to
work together
they're neighbors they come over here
you guys are treating them like crap
they don't know nothing about food
it's tearing the family apart
the way the restaurant is gone it's
gonna go broke in a month we're in the
total a million and a half dollars I
don't know if we're gonna make it we're
gonna see what we gotta do
it's too much stress
if I had to close the doors I would feel
like I failed my father in everything
that we work for together
to lose everything that I've worked for
all my life I don't know if tomorrow I'm
gonna make
I don't know if I'm gonna pay my bills
[Music]
well gone viral today and a restaurant's
reputation can live or die in seconds on
the internet so I'm here in Anaheim
visiting Luigi's Restaurant I'm going to
check out their website
uh uh wow this one looks good
um a young very talented 22 year old
Chef oh look at that clearly a youthful
maestro
less encouraging I can't wait to see
what's on the inside
um great start
22. wow
foreign
[Music]
ER excellent and you've got a bit of a
hot Chef net yes definitely could you go
get him please absolutely thank you wow
look at this place
Luigi is the Italian
oh hello Chef Ramsay a pleasure to meet
you Gordon good to see you
um hold on a minute you're not 22. I'm
51. you're 51. I'm reading the latest
report on your website a useful Maestro
22 years of age in the kitchen do you
have a son in there no it must be a
mistake yeah this was in 1981. 1981. I
have recent reviews too what like 1984
no 1991 uh 1991. anyway the food was
that good back in 1981 how is it today I
think it's better now
great news I have a following for 30
years and what I do I am the best there
is but there's some things that can be
changed youthful 22 year old like the
website who else is running the
restaurants my brother uh the Antonio
brownie that's encouraging very
encouraging in terms of a proper
family-run restaurant I have my wife
my children let's have a little catch up
with a family shall we okay yeah are
they all here yeah
my lovely wife Grace hi nice to meet you
I was going to see you where are you
from Italy this is your wife yes wow you
did well
and this is Dominica the daughter okay
wonderful and this is my brother's wife
that's my husband Antonio
how are you I'm very good attorney Tony
what would you like to be called I go by
Tony Tony okay great uh let's sit down
let's have a catch up shall we I'm glad
that Chef Ramsay is here to help us
because uh this is a family restaurant
and we shouldn't be a split Family
Restaurant first of all I'm here to help
and I can't help unless I know what's
with wrong
what's wrong with the restrooms we're a
phenomenal leader
and the leader was my father he was in
the front him and I were always on the
same page and where's your father now
where is he in Italy retired so no one's
actually ever stepped into your father's
shoes well I have
but I think what has happened is no one
has the uh idea what is needed in this
restaurant
we're in a position to lose everything
foreign
[Music]
wow it's crazy how does a family
restaurant not run as a family they
don't get along
because you never belong in this
restaurant
it's a tournament yeah we have laziness
it's an infection what happens is when
Tony is here and Linda is here they have
no understanding that number one is the
customer no sitting around no looking at
the TV watching TV when customers come
is that true
I don't think it's true
he was seen it played the computer I
care about this restaurant
the complaints are the people feel
neglected yeah but there's also
complaints like I don't want to come
there when she's there customers don't
want to come when you're working what's
all that about I don't know it's an I'm
just asking to listen I'm a she's got
people that she kisses ass too and I
love her she's got other people that she
gets blunt in her face and hate her
is it right to just basically go up to a
customer and just say [__] you get the
[__] out of here
that's what he said this is what
happened yeah yeah yeah
I'm just trying to figure out what
happened I mean I I wasn't here did she
say [__] you did she not say [__] you I
thought she did cut it here [__] you no
oh yeah
I didn't say that I said that to you
yeah
you gotta be honest I'm being honest I'm
trying to get him now let's say the way
it is I am no you're not you're lying
I'm not lying I think she's [__] you you
think so she did she did
talk we are losing the business
that's it that's why we don't get along
[Music]
within minutes of meeting the family
Chef Ramsay got a quick sample of one of
the restaurant's biggest problems
is why we don't get along follow me
thank you you're welcome now he's hoping
that the food of Luigi's is as good as
Luigi says it is uh wow I'm gonna have a
good look at the menu the menu is huge
right the menu is huge the last I
counted there was 126 things on there
okay great right let's start off with oh
before I drive early love them okay you
know what about the Linguini okay what
is the Catch of the Day
let's do that absolutely perfect thank
you so much thank you
oh
deco's hideous is stuck in a Time Walk
takes me back to 1981. okay I've a fried
ravioli for Chef Ramsay right
we made but the problem with the
restaurant because they were fighting so
much
okay my ravioli what's inside the room
really please uh it said five cheese
stuffed ravioli and the five cheeses are
I'm not sure well it's a pre-made
ravioli so not homemade those are not
homemade if we don't even make them here
be nice to know what's inside them I'll
find out right now for you thank you
how's it going I need to find out what
cheeses are in the ravioli or cheeses
are in the ravioli yeah what kind of
cheese is in the breaded ravioli read
the Box
it's a ricotta cheese dude it's a
ricotta cheese
oh my God
ah horrible for something deep fried
frozen doesn't even tastes like cheese
and
a skim cheese yeah okay perfect you got
it thank you yes yeah not good
Frozen
I checked on the cheeses for you uh
mascarpone mascarpone ricotta ricotta
also American guarana something called a
cheeseway and culture blend where the
[__] is that from in Italy I don't I
have no idea where that's from oh and a
uh skim cheese skimmed cheese in a fried
ravioli what does that mean it's fat
free cheese dipped in fat dipped in fat
yeah
okay thank you okay
skim cheese in a fried ravioli
thank you
nope awesome pants
yeah it looks good yeah Joe
tell him
[Music]
what the hell [__] this is some fish
special it's the mahi mahi
thank you you're welcome
[Music]
smush
Bland greasy no seasoning so she's
Dreadful and this is a special fish
yes that is a special fish
for you it tastes like mush almost like
it's sort of old the food just isn't the
way it used to be with all the fighting
going on the standards and the quality
everything it tanked and that's special
holy crap okay
uh he said that this one right here
where the fish was just Dreadful all
right I'm still hungry anyway
I absolutely think it's wrong about the
mahi mahi and I thought it was perfectly
fine it was just the way it's supposed
to be that's from the mountain the shaft
that knows more okay that guy's up here
and I'm down here but I know if you cook
some dinner that's his opinion I don't
want you to
[Music]
Chef Ramsay is here to help us and my
brother takes this attitude that it's
all [__] complaints it's not you got
to listen to those complaints and keep
your mouth shut
so everything is atrocious shot
are you tasting the food yeah fish was
cooked up properly it was it fresh yeah
it's mush it's excellent for me okay let
me finish this thank you thank you I
don't need a guy to tell me that my food
sucks you don't like the food you get
the [__] out here
Linguini Pescatore
yeah what the hell is that it works done
to these bits
more tentacles here than there are in
Sea World
[Music]
that tastes as bad as it looks muscles
and clams were grainy and calamari had a
weird texture to it
Chef how are you doing with the
episcopatory the struggling it's
probably struggling yeah I mean I
certainly don't get that Taste of Italy
let me tell you that and the sauce is so
weak and it tastes disgusting
um are we done yeah
yeah can't make everyone happy in life
that's why we need a help who's this
[__] I don't kiss anybody's answer
take me into the kitchen I haven't had
anyone come into my restaurant and say
Luigi you don't know what the hell
you're doing not even Chef Ramsay gets
to do that I'm frustrated I wish I could
say that was an enjoyable lunch the deep
fried ravioli with skinny cheese why did
you put that [__] on the menu to give it
to the Americans come on
come on I'm not laughing now the fish
special that was overcooked and it was
Bland that was a that was a perfect day
you're not telling me then come on it
was like cat food Linguini that one
there is the best dish in the million it
was my signature dish when I opened the
restroom I'll stick by my food I'm just
thinking for it for 30 years I have no
problem that's the problem there you've
been doing the exact same food for 30
years I haven't had a challenge in 30
years no one's ever challenged me you're
the first one listen You've Lost Your
Sparkle I don't believe this is the same
man that was the young Maestro that was
written about 30 years ago come on
there's something missing I don't know
what it is on the back of the fragmented
relationship you've got with your
brother but the heart's gone there's got
to be some magic somewhere inside that
was once there but I need it back he
can't tell me that I don't know what the
hell I'm doing in my kitchen I've been
doing it for 30 years
after being truly disappointed with
Luigi's dishes and his attitude at lunch
okay Jeff Ramsay is hoping to see
something positive during dinner service
welcome to Luigi's what can I get for
you
I'll be right back at your appetizer
started okay
uh West honey give me your number go
play some golf yeah I'm playing uh maybe
Saturday morning yeah Tony is more like
easy going now take a serious the
business job there's only seven years
between you and Luigi how come you
haven't got a gray hair he's got all the
gray hair hey try to relax more he's a
stressful guy you see what happens but
you don't like a guy that carries
pressure I try not to that's major
family problem you have to change I've
been in a solar panel with sausages I'm
going to show Chef Rams with my kitchen
runs like a machine like a smooth
machine
and the food is just coming around a
thousand miles an hour not one Chef is
tasting anything
the food always ah the kitchen really
pumps food yeah
they're they're fast they're dangerous
while food may be going up to dinos with
lightning speed the sauce is kind of
watery
what's wrong with that they said he
doesn't like the sauce on the gnocchi
it's also coming back just as quickly
um what's wrong with that now they
didn't like the flavor of the Meatballs
the solids
I'm dry as [__] and Luigi is not taking
the returns very well the lady uh wanted
the gnocchi's to be more like fluffy
like lighter than that I mean why don't
we put feathers on them we've been
making gnocchi for 30 years that's the
way it is oh my God
Luigi back in the kitchen it's kind of
scary because we never know if he's
gonna snap and yell at us for something
oh why the [__] you better answer back
and you don't get the mushrooms that's
all like I told you I did put them over
there
before it goes out
I didn't taste this one one complaints
without my old future it's close
everything down that's what it is one
and I have all the complaints at one
time what's wrong with you
you know better than me
sure one day the arrogance
is not true arrogance of the chef yes
apparently was good arrogant Chef just
like me worse than me why are you
shouting at me I'm not shouting you're
not shouting a little bit crazy
if you do it no you know better than me
[Music]
thank you
it's just halfway into dinner service
why don't you come here and tell me how
it's done Chef you do it no you know
better than me
but after a series of complaints
Luigi has had enough that's it no he's
not gone he's gone wait hold off for
lunch he's not gone yeah I'm gonna go
back and fight
[Music]
and you gotta understand what he's
trying to do here man
he's he's not
the guy is what he is and he's [__]
[__] English bastard is what it is
all right yeah but he's being honest
with us
not being honest with us yeah he is no
it's not a bunch of [__] man this
restaurant is it's both our restaurant
so I want to patch things up I want to
get along with him he's my brother I
wanted to pass for him I think you got
to go back in there and finish this
[__] night off man and don't have my
don't back down from the [__]
man I'm not backing down all right
you're just taking a break I'm too hot
all right
[Music]
mom
come here
bring that out underneath the best
Italian food West of Italy yeah still
the best food Western below you put your
food against mine anytime you want
really I work with more chefs than you
can imagine in the past the way you
perform tonight
did not tell me that is a man that is in
control of his kitchen
I'm gonna come out and read that [__]
I'm pissed off for you and your
customers it's 2011. unfortunately Luigi
no one's [__] told you
that's my opinion tonight's service
oh what the [__] are we supposed to do
man
I need your help
[Music]
there's something quite remarkable about
how hard you work but I want you working
[__] smarter not harder when you come
down
and come back to 2011 you've got me
[Music]
world famous Italian Family Restaurant
[__] me
foreign
how dysfunctional Luigi's really is good
morning good morning
Chef Ramsey brothers and their wives and
he knows just how to do that so when was
the last time you had a meeting a
meeting with all the staff never five
years
wow four of you need one voice put
across to all of your staff come through
to the kitchen come with me I want you
to watch something very very interesting
just stay here I'll see you in a minute
thank you
wow ever
morning come in come in come in good
morning
take a uh take a seat please okay I
asked you here this morning because I've
never seen a restaurant operate the way
this one does and I can't start to fix
anything unless I know what the problems
are
just gonna be honest
when you go back to the to the kitchen
and tell Tony Garcia
whoever the client is complaining about
this you get a big fight
as the people tell you they don't like
it you can't have Luigi what do you mean
they don't like it what's wrong with it
your recipe and that must be kind of
tough to like take criticism but you're
gonna have to like bend your will a
little bit to what the customer wants
somebody needs to taste the food before
it comes out we shouldn't be checking
the quality of the food in the back two
years ago three years ago it's been
declining in your mind for the last two
years absolutely
I get stressed out when I come to work
one
just the atmosphere the complete vibe
that we get the disorganization that we
have there's no structure it comes from
the top what is the top we're not
organized at all how fragmented is it
it's just like Grace and Luigi versus my
mom and Tony
it's very separate the conflict with
these two families the clients can feel
it and who wants to go to a place where
the atmosphere is not the most Pleasant
so the conflicts
with the family is spilling into the
dining room yes do you agree absolutely
the yelling and screaming who's yelling
primarily who is it easily I think the
biggest yellow is grays
I never know if I'm going to walk in and
she's going to be smiling or someone
should have frown on her face and start
yelling at the concert
I'm saying what they say and you have to
let other people talk
the money lying she gets like really mad
and start telling you things that first
of all they're embarrassing for our
customers and second of all they're not
professional that's destroying
everyone's confidence I feel this pain
[Music]
has anyone sat down and spoke to her
I'm just afraid to say anything to her
because I don't know if she's gonna yell
at me could you not take criticism no
she can't take racism she can't nothing
no no criticism whatsoever
I don't want to hear it anymore and if
she does change her mind she'll say that
she didn't change it that she's always
thought that
crazy okay
uh
just stay here for a second please I
don't care anymore I don't know I don't
care about the restaurants I feel like
everybody gets me they talk nice and in
front of you they're stepping you back
anymore
[Music]
so bad
nothing talk to me no I can't talk I
just want to quit that's it I want to
leave I don't want to be all in the
distance
about me so I can think
anymore
there we go
listen to me
[Music]
Chef Ramsay has arranged away for the
owners to hear how the staff feels about
their behavior I just want to quit
that's it I want to leave I don't want
to be all in the distance and it's all
too much for Grace to handle
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
my god
listen to me listen to me
foreign
[Music]
Grace that is the feeling of your team
and they are here for you and you have
to listen to them we cannot start to fix
this restaurant unless we fix each other
first so I'm sorry you feel it's upset
but that's the first time you've seen
the way you affect them
but let's just stay calm and let's go
and have a meeting together and talk as
a family okay okay
let's go
I think Grace needed to hear all these
criticisms she still is a little bit in
denial of the way that she is and how it
intimidates other people I think
eventually she will come through but
it's going to be hard for her you take a
seat just a big deep breath the owners
were listening
the minute I walked in here I could feel
the level of intensity it was it was
depressing nobody was being honest with
each other and we continued to fall
along these lines and remain broken this
ration is going to close and whether you
like it or not you're all tied together
and if we can't work and communicate
together as a family then you shouldn't
be in business because it's unfair it's
unfair
[Music]
one thing we are going to do from this
day on is work together can everyone
agree on that yes yes good past is past
okay see look that smile I was kind of
already almost to give up
I know the truth hurts and I know it can
help us I know it'll get better
thank you
after an emotional breakthrough as a
result of the staff meeting after you
let's go let's go let's go Jeff Ramsey
has an idea on how to get the family
working together again when you think of
Italy you think of spicy sausage yes yes
when was the last time we made a spicy
sausage when I was a younger girl I used
to make sausage with your parents oh
yeah already
I wasn't 10 years old when I started to
make a flush with my parents whereas in
Calabria I feel like I'm back young girl
okay so tonight we'll make a brand new
delicious Luigi sauces I'll start off
slowly grinding
how big do you like your sausage
[Music]
me hungry my job was to stuff the
sausage I love it
and you know initially the sausage
brings a family together it's a nice
feeling right yeah so when was the last
time we all spent time in the kitchen
together when was that
never never
[Music]
wow this piece that we are trying to get
to right now is long overdue when my
father was here we were happy happy
place it's been too many years and too
many frustrations going on I want you
too brother-in-law sister-in-law to make
the rest of them Louise and I are going
to go and cook okay all right nice just
to see like Tony and Grace working
together making sausage give me a little
bit of hope it's a beautiful thing
making me feel younger it's very fun
okay
sausage is it
for the sauce I'm gonna make it like a
nice sort of Rich Ragu
AR fresh freshly used oh yes working
next to Chef Ramsay it's a great great
opportunity the way that he works and
the passion that he has it makes me uh
me a light of fire and he said why can't
I do that like I used to think in the
old days I would love to be in the
kitchen here when you were 22. you know
that yeah it would have been fun can you
imagine I started to realize I still
have the passion right are you ready
you're ready
you're done at a 21st century that's a
little taste simple fresh Italian Flair
jump in
oh man that's awesome me and Grace
worked hard on those sausages I I feel
as though it's just the first little
baby step and I can do better right I
want to do better good job oh my gosh
unbelievable yeah very good oh my gosh
it's too good
now that Chef Ramsay has seen a glimmer
of hope with the family working together
Luigi we are relaunching this restaurant
tomorrow he has one more surprise in
store to make sure Tony and Luigi stay
United I want all of you right now to
watch something
[Music]
listen good night
it's a day your father
it's been five years since I've seen my
father I miss him I love him
I wish I was close to them
[Music]
in this opportunities
don't forget that beautiful Taco we have
together
please
[Music]
me
and God bless everybody
[Music]
remind me of the past remind me of where
we came from and how we started why we
started this kind of business you know
why we're in it
if it's back in perspective
[Music]
we'll make this place and do what it
needs to go to do
whatever it takes
starting tomorrow
[Music]
you'll see a new Luigi
I guarantee it
[Music]
after arranging for an emotional message
from Luigi and Tony's father Chef Ramsay
and his team worked through the night to
bring a little piece of Italy to Luigi's
[Music]
today we start off with a new attitude a
new restaurant and a new beginning are
you ready to see the new Luigi's yes
on the count of three one
two three
[Music]
oh wow welcome to New Luigis
everything has been themed as if we're
on this amazing trip to Italy it's
appealing it's vibrant and it's got that
rustic Italian charm beautiful
John is the Clutter gone are those
horrible booze now we have this
wonderful nice family style bunker
seating look at the tables underneath
we've got the Luigi's stamp of approval
beautiful even the napkins have got your
stamp on there Grace what do you think
unbelievable unbelievable
I remember now how it was with my dad
and I hardly worked to get this
restaurant started
Luigi You're Going Quiet I get nervous
when you're quiet no I'm very very happy
thank you sir thank you listen I hope
that you are re-energized
I didn't know you give them out I know
you're the best this is just a dream
I'm Dreaming I'm asleep is unbelievable
it's a new Luigi's
[Music]
[Applause]
after giving the restaurant a much
needed makeover Chef Ramsay has also
given the menu a dramatic makeover as
well welcome to the new menu it's fresh
it's seasonal and it's exciting oh
beautiful beautiful wow
yeah what have we done we simplified it
and made it manageable and delicious
okay let's start off with the appetizer
a lovely bowl of seasonal minestrone
with a fresh pesto pasta dishes down the
bottom yes linguine yellow clam
delicious and then finally baked salmon
for a light take on supper when we just
start to eat let me finish please I'm
sorry is she always like this always
a joke one thing you do deserve Luigi
yeah it's a medal for me married to
Grace
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
get jump in get tasting
oh wow it's really good
so good I'm sure everybody's awesome
short ribs are good it reminds me of
some moms to make the new menu is
amazing I love it I think this is a
slice of authentic Italy in Anaheim
lasagna is excellent really good we have
the restaurant that looks like a modern
place we have a new menu everybody is
smiling everybody's happy again I really
feel fantastic everything is excellent
I'll be proud to serve this food
[Music]
welcome to the new Luigi's it's relaunch
night at Luigi's we are serving the new
menu so would you like to start off with
any appetizers
calamari and for the first time in a
long time there's positive energy
Cooks Tony new expedite right right Chef
let's get those first orders in please I
don't want Luigi panicking I'm gonna get
spaghetti and before homemade sausage
want to kill him
here we go
order in first one
is
Chef Ramsay has lit up another Fire
Within me that it's gonna burn for a
long time okay let's go let's go guys
Norwegian public much better like that
[Music]
so good with Luigi producing stunning
dishes in the kitchen diners are
thrilled with Chef Ramsay's new menu
that's delicious and the kitchen is
having no trouble keeping up with the
demand
pick up
[Music]
while food is getting to the hot plate
in a timely manner
Tony and Luigi have stopped coordinating
and the Log Jam in the kitchen is not
sitting well with diners
I need my brother to come in and give me
some help I get frustrated and I get mad
and I want to kill the guy what's going
on
[Music]
it's relaunch night and while the
kitchen continues to produce food Tony
what's going on let's pick up the pace
all right I'll be right there a lack of
communication between the brothers has
resulted in food sitting on the pass and
not at diners tables getting called Tony
service please let's go
Luigi you have to keep this together if
you start screaming I'll kick you out if
I lose my fool again in front of the
customers it's definitely going to cost
my business all right let's go let's go
let's go I gotta learn to take a deep
breath and get it back together Tony
look at me look at me now we're
producing unique food and it's dying
he's cooking you can't stand there like
a lemon you've got to help him a little
bit we can't cook like this and let the
food die in the window I need you
Expediting talk to each other start
pushing the food out let's go I don't
need a fried calamari on that one
hey Dominica Dominica take this to right
here at table 41. that sounds like a
kitchen we've got some voices in there I
I still need one more pescatory with
Tony now concentrating on Expediting
what else we got fake salmon in the
chicken farm wonderful wonderful Luigi
is free to focus on the quality and the
consistency of the food
fettuccine alfredo diners are once again
enjoying the new Luigis
okay thank you Chef we're finally
leaving the negativity and the fighting
behind us good things will come with a
good attitude this first step was great
yes sir
okay tonight we took a baby step forward
in the right direction slow start but
the customers were happy and yes we were
a little bit like headless chickens but
you showed you had passion yes
[Applause]
two brothers step forward
look at you too
honestly that's exactly what I want to
see you've made the critical First Step
but stay on it stay on that path I
haven't shared things together is
something special the brothers need to
be blinded I think my father would be
very proud love is back and Luigi's Stay
Together
you make him look good and you make him
look good thank you very much Chef
Ramsey you're the Princeton white
shining armor you walked into our place
and you give soap and courage again
[Music]
no screaming
[Applause]
wow I have never in all the years our
Kitchen Nightmares seen a more explosive
family situation than here at Luigi's
they're so busy fighting each other the
reputation of the restaurant went
completely downhill this week we moved
them forward 30 years
but unless this family stays United
Luigi's has no chance and I mean no
chance of success
in the weeks that followed Luigi's
received a rave review from the OC
Weekly the revamped dining room was
slammed all sorts of delights passed us
by yeah this is fantastic and the
restaurant is regaining the reputation
it once held in the community
wow that's Luigi
and unbelievably awesome thank you
you're welcome the family is working
together in harmony
Chef Ramsay is about the family together
again and my father in Italy is going to
be proud of us with us we put all our
differences aside and I think we're
gonna build a new bright future for all
of us